How does he become corrupt and for a
person to avoid the dangers of the
postmodern,
neo Marxist ideologies and not enroll?
Would you agree the same thing applies
to the institute of marriage with laws
as they are?
No,
I wouldn't say that.
I guess partly because I don't
understand what the alternative is.
First,
I would say that to the degree that men
are just your unjustly upset about the
way the marriage laws are set up and I
think they have reason to be concerned,
especially with regards to the custody
of children and the probability of
paying virtually endless alimony with
unbelievably severe penalties for
failure.
Um,
I think that it's incumbent on men to
organize themselves politically and
rectify that.